Get on the fucking floor.
You don't need
a phone, babe.
It's bad for you,
all that social media,
and staring at the screen
all day, and…
And the radiation, 5G,
can't be good for the baby.
What the fuck are
you talking about?
You know I don't like it
when you talk like that.
-You can go now.
-I'll come with you.
Curtis.
No. No, this is private.
Why is it private?
'Cause a woman
has to have her secrets.
You would know
if you was a woman.
But, baby,
I've seen everything.
Curtis, please, can I just
have some privacy?
I'm only going in there
to try some things on.
Please.
-Fuck.
-Oi!
-Hey!
-No, no, no!
-Stop the car!
-Oi!
-Alright, OK.
-Stop the car!
-No! No!
-Hey, mate!
Don't let them in the back!
That's my wife, mate.
She's sick. She needs help.
Come on, mate.
Open the door for me, yeah?
Alright, OK,
I'm unlocking it.
-I'm unlocking it.
-No! Don't let them in!
-Hey!
-Open it!
-Open the fucking car!
-Alright.
Listen to me, cunt.
Open the fucking car.
Open the fucking door!
-No!
-Fucking bitch!
Yes, that's right.
I know exactly
who you are, Curtis.
Hear what I'm telling you.
If you've done anything
to hurt her, I swear down--
Jaq…
I'm glad we're on
first name terms now.
Oh, fuck.
After all, we both
want the same thing.
We both want Lauryn
to be safe…
and happy.
There's no need for threats.
I ain't made
no threats, bruv.
I understand
that you're anxious, Jaq,
but Lauryn is my world.
Lauryn.
Shall I call
the police, Naomi?
There won't be any need
for that, Naomi, eh?
I just need to make
contact with Lauryn.
It's an urgent
family matter.
So if you could get
a message to her
or Shelley,
or even Jaq,
I'd be grateful.
I'm hearing you're on
a mad one with Lauryn.
Locking her away like
she's a hostage and that.
Confiscating her phone,
telling her
what she can wear.
What sort of man does
that to his baby mother,
and then expects her
to stay?
Don't make no sense.
Look, Dushane…
I'm here to take Lauryn back
where she belongs.
Question is,
how do we make that happen?
Are you a woman
of your word, Naomi?
Yeah.
Good. So, that's a promise
you'll keep then?
Yes.
You're going to do
two things for me.
Firstly, don't buy property
in Manchester, it's a dump.
Buy in Liverpool instead.
Secondly, tell Dushane
if he wants what's his,
he needs to bring
me my Lauryn.
Did you hear me?
Is that clear?
Hello, Dushane.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Go!
That's the idea.
It's a trap.
And they think you're stupid
enough to fall into it.
Now they've fallen
into our trap.
We're gonna snatch Jaq.
What?
Jaq for Lauryn.